In the last part of the problem
we figured out that the
function of the height of the
ferris wheel, the people at the
ferris wheel at any time is a
function of t. h of t is equal
to 9 minus 8 cosine of 18t
where t is in seconds.
Now the second part of this
problem they want us to graph h
as a function of t between 0 is
less than or equal to t, is
less than or equal to 30.
So let me draw axes.
So let's say that
that's my h-axis.
Let's say that this
is my t-axis.
So this is t equals 0, and this
is t is equal to 30 seconds.
I get confused when I see
this 18 here or whatever.
So what I'm going to do first
of all is I'm going to graph a
different function, slightly
different function, then I'll
translate it to this function.
I'm going to graph h of
theta is equal to 9
minus 8 cosine of theta.
I think you'll see where
I'm going with this
when I'm all done.
So let's try to graph h
of theta is equal to 9
minus 8 cosine of theta.
So when t is equal
to 30 seconds, what
is theta equal to?
So 30 times 18, that's 540.
So this is 540 degrees.
Same thing.
I'll write the thetas in
red above the t-axis.
This is 540 degrees, so
that's like two times
around the circle.
So that's 540 degrees,
then this is going to
be roughly 270 degrees.
So, 90 degrees will be
about 1/3 of this.
That would be 90 degrees, that
would be 180, so that would be
90 degrees, that would be 180
degrees, this would be 360
degrees, and this would be 360
plus 90 so this will
be 450 degrees.
If you wanted to figure out
the corresponding time,
you just take this
degree and divide by 18.
So it's 90 divided
by 18 is what?
It's five, right?
So if I were to write here,
this is at 5 seconds, this is
at 10 seconds, this is 15
seconds, this is 20 seconds,
this is -- sorry, this is 25
seconds, this is 30 seconds.
Actually, a simple thing we
could do is let's just figure
out what the value of the
function is at these points.
Because these are pretty
easy degrees to figure out
what the cosine value is.
So let's figure out --
let me draw a table.
Tables are always good and
I'll do it in yellow.
So I'll draw a t theta and h.
This might be kind of an
unconventional way of doing
things, but I have a simple
mind so this is actually
how I like to do it.
So I like to think of
theta as 0, 90, 180,
270, 360, 450 and 540.
And t, the corresponding
time of those, as 0,
5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30.
It's not rocket science here.
When t equals 15 seconds,
15 times 18, we're trying
to find the cosine of
270 degrees, right?
15 times 18 is 270 degrees.
I'm just doing this because I
don't have a calculator and
this will help me
pick good points.
So when t is equal to
0, what is height?
Or t is equal to 0, theta is
equal to 0, so cosine of theta
is -- cosine of 0 is 1.
So 9 minus 8 is 1.
I'm going to do h in
a different color.
So this is 1.
Cosine of 90 degrees?
Cosine of 90 degrees is 0.
So 9 minus 0 is 9.
Cosine of 180 degrees?
So we're going all the way
around the unit circle.
Cosine of 180
degrees is minus 1.
So minus 1 times minus 8 is
plus 8, so 9 plus 8, that's 15.
Cosine of 270 degrees are
pointing straight down, so the
x-coord is going to be 0.
So once again,
we're at 9 again.
9 minus 0.
360 degrees.
Cosine of 360 degrees
is the same thing as
cosine of 0, right?
So once again, I mean we've
gone around the circle once.
So it's going to be the same
as 0, so it's going to be 1.
And 450 is going to be
the same thing as 90.
So it's going to be 9
and then 15 degrees.
So let's plot these points.
Actually, let me just
draw 15 up here.
So what are the points
that keep showing up?
So this is 1, that's 1, that's
1, and then we have 9.
1, there's 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
Fair enough.
So let me draw some
guidelines just to help us.
Actually, let me do them kind
of hard to see, because I
don't want to draw too much
attention to the guidelines.
I could do one guideline there.
Then I'll do a bottom
guideline right there.
Then the 9 keeps showing up.
Oh, you know what, I can't add.
What's 9 plus 8?
It's not 15, it's 17.
Sorry, clearly, I need to
practice my addition.
So this is 9 plus
8, this is 17.
And I realized that because I
was like, well 9 should be in
the middle, so this
is actually 17.
Ignore my little marks here.
That's 17, this is 1.
Ignore the marks.
9 would be right in the
middle between 1 and 17.
So let me draw kind of
mediant point right there.
So this is 9.
Sorry I can't add properly.
Then let's draw the graph
or at least plot the
points on the graph.
So, t equals 0 where h equals
1, so that's this point.
That's right here.
When t equals 5, h is
equal to 9, right here.
When t is equal to 10,
h is equal to 17.
When t is equal to
15, h is 9 again.
So it's right here.
At 20 we're back at 1.
I think you see the pattern.
At 25 we're back at 9.
And then at 30 we're back at
17, not 15, because now I
have corrected my mistake.
And this is going to be sined
graph, it's going to look
something like this.
Let me do it in a vibrant color
so I can overwrite everything
and it's going to look
something like this.
Go oops, and then up
and them down here.
Curve up, come back down, curve
up and then come back down.
Like that.
So that's our graph.
I think in the problem they
tell us to approximate.
Actually, let me open up my
cousin's problem -- my other
account has timed-out on
me while I recorded this.
They wanted to approximate when
t equals 4 what the height is.
So when t equals 4 the
height is like right
around there, right?
So the height is a
little bit less than 9.
And I don't know, 7 or
8 meters in the air.
And when time is equal to 10 --
well, time equal 10, we figured
out exactly, we know that there
are 17 meters in the air.
So I know this was kind of a
little messy and graphing
trick functions tend to be,
but hopefully you found
this vaguely useful.
Have fun.